[Musik]
charlotte würdig sagt sommerurlaub in
corona zeiten ich habe im moment echt
andere probleme die zentec allmacht
selten urlaub sagt sich aber um die
menschen die gerade jetzt absolut
urlaubsreif sind patricia platil will
dass wir an die kleinen tourismus
betreiber denken die stehen kurz vor der
pleite
unser gast aus glas sagt innerdeutsch
wird man sicherlich verreisen können und
damit herzlich willkommen wir legen
direkt los wollen gar keine zeit
verlieren die reisewarnung wurden gerade
verlängert was bedeutet das jetzt für
uns folgendes jetzt endgültig vom
sommerurlaub verabschieden war es dass
dieses jahr die hier bei euch damit vom
party urlaub kann man sich definitiv
verabschieden nicht nur vor dem
hintergrund von ischgl sondern ich
glaube es geht wirklich um die frage wie
definieren wir urlaub künftig ich weiß
nicht wie es euch geht aber ich finde es
ist ja auch die wiederentdeckung von
selbstverständlichkeiten die man dann
doch als besonders erachtet und da finde
ich schon wichtig dass man natürlich die
sicherheit gewährleistet deutschlandweit
europaweit ich bin mir sicher und ich
hoffe auch dass das gelingt denn wir
dürfen diesen psychologischen bruch in
der gesellschaft nicht unterschätzen
und deswegen ist für mich die urlaubs
debatte auch keine luxus debatte sondern
sie es immer nennt wichtig insbesondere
auch für die elternteile die kein garten
haben die keinen balkon haben sich
darüber gedanken zu machen und die
aufgabe ist jetzt wie schaffen wir es
das infektionsrisiko einzudämmen
sozusagen als gemeinsame maßnahme und
trotzdem urlaub herzberg aber ich bin
total crazy dass wir über urlaub
diskutieren wenn ich nun nicht mal mit
meinem vierjährigen sohn schaukeln gehen
darf dass er heute ja da waren da in die
kita waren über geht die schule los und
wir reden über urlaub das denn das
stresst mich tatsächlich noch viel viel
mehr
also für mich ist urlaub seitdem ich
kinder hat sowieso eher alltag unter
erschwerten bedingungen also ich hab
nicht mehr dieses wirkliche urlaub ich
verstehe aber dass die menschen urlaub
brauchen dass man darauf hinarbeitet
also ich denke da vor allem an die
menschen die beengt wohnen an die
menschen die sich jetzt seit wochen für
uns einsetzen die in systemrelevanten
jobs und dient also
doch irgendwie highlights und aber
machen den rückfall haben gerade weil
wir jetzt alles lockern und uns jetzt
auf einmal alles traut dem sitzen im
herbst da und müssen viele noch viel
länger ja ich denke man muss schon
irgendwie hoffnung haben und vertrauen
haben und wenn es dann wieder anders ist
dann ist es halt anders aber wenn man
jetzt schon gleich alles wieder schwarz
reden sagt das geht alles nicht lass uns
mal hoffen dass es gut geht und wenn es
nicht gut geht dann müssen halt nochmal
in diesen sauren apfel beißen sich auch
so ein bisschen wieder und das ist ja
auch eine chance in dieser zeit sei die
basics besinnen dass man sagt es muss
vielleicht nicht immer der bombastische
cluburlaub mit einem pipapo sein sondern
es reicht vielleicht auch mal wenn man
einfach eine kleine fahrradtour macht
irgendwie in heimat urlaub dessen
rausbekommt irgendwie schaut wie
schaut's vor der eigenen haustür aus
dass es eben die kleinen dinge sind die
jetzt wieder noch alle spielen wir waren
ja auch diese menschenrechte gegen
freiheitsrechte soll ich mal und
menschenleben gewährleisten heißt auch
die psyche zu bedenken und das ist eben
nicht nur corona sondern da geht es auch
um vieles anderes und um freiheitsrechte
und ich glaube dass urlaub erweitert
auch dazu gehören genau dazu hat ja auch
der bundestagspräsident geäußert der
schäuble hat ein bisschen was dazu
gesagt dass gucken uns mal an
bundespräsident wolfgang schäuble sagte
in einem interview
aber wenn ich höre alles andere habe vor
dem schutz von leben zurück zu treten
dann muss ich sagen das ist in dieser
absolutheit nicht richtig grundrechte
beschränkten sich gegenseitig wenn es
überhaupt einen absoluten wert in
unserem grundgesetz gibt dann ist das
die würde des menschen ist unantastbar
da sind ganz ganz große worte und die
sind natürlich für uns alle auch
irgendwo einleuchtend und die tun auch
gut in dieser zeit so was zu hören
natürlich liegt das trotz möchte das mit
in unsere diskussion mit reinnehmen was
bewegt es bei euch hell denk dir jetzt
anders darüber
ich finde immer ich habe in dieser
ganzen krise zunehmend das gefühl
genommen das ist ganz vielen politikern
darum geht ihre profilneurosen noch mal
nach draußen zu tragen also das ganz
klar ist ich möchte jetzt noch mal was
sagen total bewiesen hat dass dieses
wettrennen zwischen söder und lasche
wehrmacht die alle paar jahre konferenz
nach der merkel also ich bin ich bin das
wird die zwei streithähne die sich nur
noch darauf konzentriert haben politik
zu betreiben das brauchen wir gerade
nicht wir sind in einer pandemie in
einer situation die wir so noch nie
hatten und bei mir macht es ein
vertrauensverlust ich frage mich geht es
eigentlich um und setzt aber geht's
nicht auf drum um eine gewisse balance
das muss ich nicht auf 1 konzentriert
und dann viele dinge außer acht lässt
bei natürlich die würde des menschen ist
unantastbar
das ist ja eigentlich eine wunderbare
aussage betrifft jeden menschen und ich
glaube schon dass man natürlich in der
unsicherheit dass man sagt wir wollen
alles richtig machen und alles ist so
ist er auch dieses sei immer
anführungszeichen wegsperren von der
risikogruppe wo ich zum beispiel gehöre
eine große belastung für diese menschen
und dass deswegen glaube ich schon
dies ist alles ich glaube dass kein
politiker jetzt etwas tut und sagt ich
will ich die exer mal rein reiten und
bin mal spaßbremse und macht dies oder
jenes ich glaube dass die leute das
richtig machen wollen
aber ich denke das ist ein kritisches
überdenken ist denn alles wichtig ganz
richtig oder kann ich auch ein bisschen
wo was öffnen das vielleicht mal die oma
und opa doch die enkelkinder wenigstens
von weitem sehen dürfen und oder am
spielplatz jetzt gott sei dank wieder
vielleicht also ich denke wir müssen
schon ein bisschen
auch da unsere hoffnung nähern das ist
in china ganz abgesperrt also ich glaube
auch mit dieser hoffnung und dieser
aspekt menschenleben ist das oberste
primat also das sehen wir ja alle gleich
ja das darf man dann eben nicht nur
reduzieren auf cupid 19
sondern wenn wir nun alle anderen
krankheiten dabei berücksichtigen und
wir tun ja geradezu so als wenn wir das
nie riskieren würden also auch
menschenleben nicht riskieren würden und
das stimmt ja nur bedingt also denken
wir an die 3000 toten 2009 10 aufgrund
von verkehrsunfällen haben wir deswegen
den verkehr abgeschafft nein haben wir
nicht und da glaube ich ist es ganz ganz
wichtig dass man das nicht gegeneinander
laufen lässt sondern dass man diese
parallelität eben auch zulässt denn
insbesondere auch das was sie hier
machen auch in den sozialen engagement
wenn wir jetzt über diese kinder
sprechen beispielsweise der ein
frühstück bekommt also was da im moment
auch hinter verborgenen türen passiert
das muss man ja auch berücksichtigt aber
das macht auch krank und davon kann man
auch irgendwann sterben wie geht es euch
den persönlich fühlt ihr euch durch
diesen von mir gesagt liebe von chip
down mittlerweile vor dem showdown
fühlt ihr euch er eingesperrt oder fühlt
ihr euch sicher dadurch weil da scheiden
sich eigentlich schon die geister
also natürlich mir geht's so mir fehlt
die decke auf den kopf ich habe einen
lagerkoller
er könnte es mir aussuchen möchte ich in
urlaub fahren möchte raus und möchte vor
allem der betreuung für meine kinder
gutes wurde jetzt heute ein bisschen in
aussicht gestellt dass man damit rechnen
kann
natürlich aber ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen wir sind nicht eingesperrt es geht
uns nicht sowie anderen ländern wo man
nur eine stunde am tag raus tage nach um
einkäufe zu machen und und sport zu
bezahlen das würde in meinem fall auch
noch ausfallen also alles nur noch um
einkaufen zu gehen sondern wir haben
wahnsinnig viele freiheiten und es mir
so wahnsinnig naja ich finde wir jammern
natürlich jetzt in der runde
das traue ich einfach sagen auf das
vermessung niveau da müssen wir an die
familien denken vielleicht eine
zweizimmerwohnung haben kein balkon
ihrer heim garten und nix und die können
dann auch nur bedingt raus und ich finde
da ist die not hinter den türen
riesengroß und ich glaube dass das eine
große ein großes leiden ist vor allem
für die kinder auch für frauen natürlich
ist überhaupt keine frage
mit einem mann und der andere vielleicht
auch leiden aber endeffekt ich glaube
dass es nicht nur hunger gibt sondern
dass es auch ganz viel gewalt gibt ja
sowieso
und die ließ also das ist sozusagen ein
leiden was still und unsichtbar ja und
das findet eben nicht den zugang in
einem medienöffentlichkeit des und da
müssen die erlaube ich auch ganz genau
hinhören und selbst der begriff social
des dancing ist ein luxusproblem für
menschen in flüchtlingslagern die gar
keinen rückzugspunkt haben und ich sage
immer dass diese krise nicht gleich
macht sondern ungleich und gerade auch
vor dem hintergrund dass ganz viel auch
verglichen und geguckt wird und da muss
man glaube ich auch sehr faktoren gleich
weil es ungleich es machen gleiche was
derzeit gibt in den knochen und gleicht
ja ja ich finde überhaupt nicht dass die
krise gleich macht dann ist es ein
riesenunterschied ob ich den garten habe
oder eben nicht na ja logisch also wenig
absolut recht genau deswegen glaube ich
auch ist jetzt neben sozusagen der
bekämpfung der pandemie
ganz wichtig auch was für gesellschafts
konzept haben wir denn
und wie passen wir jetzt gegenseitig
aufeinander auf und da wünsche ich mir
natürlich auch konzepte an dem wir
selber beteiligt sein müssen also dass
da gerade gefragt wie geht es euch im
moment also wir haben alle hände voll zu
tun auch mit denen menschenrechtsverein
sozialunternehmen aber wir merken auch
den leidensdruck der menschen die hilfe
suchen auf antworten warten die wir
gerade nicht haben ich meine das merkt
man ja auch sei allein schon wenn man
den supermarkt geht nicht dass die
stimmung so langsam aber sicher bei
sachen kippt wo man vom paar wochen noch
irgendwie darüber gelächelt hätte
[Musik]